der tagesordnung und dazu begrüße ich
ganz herzlich dem
bundesgesundheitsminister herr
lauterbach herzlich willkommen und auf
der rechten seite von jonas hat platz
genommen professor dr leif erik sander
er ist klinikdirektor für infektiologie
an der berliner charité auch an sie ein
herzliches willkommen
in zeiten von krone wird diese
pressekonferenz
glaube ich gestreamt dann auch live
übertragen deshalb unsere übliche
vorbemerkung die bundespressekonferenz
ist keine institution der
bundesregierung sondern ein unabhängiger
verein von journalistinnen und
journalisten
wir veranstalten pressekonferenzen damit
unsere mitgliedschaft besser informieren
kann sodass der vorrede und jetzt hat
sie das wort herr lauterbach bitteschön
ja vielen dank vielen dank für die eine
für die möglichkeit hier unsere
positionen vortragen zu dürfen erneut
möchte zunächst an professor wieler und
das robert-koch-institut entschuldigen
urlaubsbedingt kam er heute nicht
teilnehmen heute werde ich unterstützt
durch ein live ihre sandra so sander von
der charité wird ihnen über den stand
der impfungen und über die lage für
krone derzeit berichten
die
situation ist wie folgt zu beschreiben
wir haben eine günstige entwicklung
bei der sommer welle sollen wir da war
ja antizipiert worden diese novelle
fängt jetzt langsamer an zurückzugehen
sind stetig sinken der fallzahlen auch
die sterblichkeit geht gott sei dank
nach langer zeit jetzt etwas zurück ist
aber immer noch nicht da wo wir sie
gerne hätten
man muss bedenken dass der anteil der
nicht
registrierten fälle gewachsen ist die
dunkelziffer steigt das wissen wir aus
dem tal
projektdaten spende des
robert-koch-instituts neuer daten der
brocken haben uns da in den letzten
tagen reicht nicht desto trotz ist der
rückgang der fall sei jetzt artefakt
sondern ist echt das zeigen auch diese
fehlen passen
also mit den daten die wir haben einen
robusten rückgang der fallzahlen auch in
anderen europäischen ländern gesehen
haben und das gibt es aber grund zur
freude
dass es trotzdem kein grund für eine
entwarnung denn die modellierung die es
gibt und auch also die dynamik ab fünf
schnelle lassen erwarten dass im herbst
wenn wieder mehr aufenthalt in
innenräumen stattfindet und auch die
schule wieder begonnen hat dass wir dann
wieder stark steigende fallzahlen
erwarten müssen dass es auch andere
gründe das hatte ich ihnen gleich das
infektionsschutzgesetz noch einmal etwas
näher erläutern werde als bisher machen
konnten ich bin aber zunächst einmal
eine so positive nach ich habe sehr gute
nachrichten der entwicklung der
impfungen ist davon auszugehen dass das
europäische zulassungsbehörde sich also
mit dem baa1 bivalenten impfstoff
am ersten september schon beschäftigen
wird so dass möglicherweise dann also am
zweiten september die auslieferung
erfolgen könnte und wir haben nachricht
das ist wahrscheinlich nächstes am 27
september die entsprechende
gremiensitzung zu b a 5 bivalent
stattfinden würde so dass dann die
auslieferung am 28 september stattfinden
könnte die bundesregierung hat ja so
beide impfstoffe in auskömmliche menge
besorgt und wir werden daher relativ
früh auch beliefert werden das bedeutet
dass die von uns geplante und in
vorbereitung befindliche kampagne dann
auch zeitnah stattfinden kann und wie
cloud also im prinzip guter unterwegs
sind das gilt auch für viele andere
vorbereitung schickte panamera da
beispielsweise oder bugs ovid
vorbereitung darauf würde ich aber nur
in frage in frage teilen eingehen weil
ich jetzt also mich konzentrieren möchte
auch den zweiten tag meiner ausführungen
nämlich auf das infektionsschutzgesetz
zunächst einmal ist da der stand dann
also 24 8 und wollen mit dem gesetz im
kabinett sein so wie es jetzt also norm
entwurf vorliegt die begründung wird
überarbeitet haben haben wir gestern
intensiv gearbeitet anfang september
wurde dann das gesetz im deutschen
bundestag geschossen und in der nächsten
woche werden wir eine seite mit den
leitern der staatskanzleien haben erneut
um also es auch mit den ländern
auszutauschen und abzustimmen sie wissen
dass in der letzten und das in dieser
woche auch eine
gesundheitsministerkonferenz
stattgefunden hat am dienstag und wie
gesagt nächster woche leiter der
staatskanzlei sodass jetzt verfahren
bisher zeitlich nicht gefährdet ist und
ich komme jetzt zum inhalt des neuen
textes das sind ja zwei stufen
beschrieben die erste stufe als
winterreifen stufe beschrieben die also
zweiter schnupfen als schneeketten also
stufe man kann auch einfach von der
ersten und der zweiten stufe sprechen
nicht begrenzte mich daher auf diese
wortwahl im moment die erste stufe
funktioniert wie folgt zunächst einmal
ab dem 1 zehnten würde wenn man jetzt
einmal von maßnahmen im öffentlichen
fernverkehr absicht und in den kliniken
und pflegeeinrichtungen über die wir als
bund also bestimmen können nur bestimmte
verschärfungen der geltenden regeln
beschlossen haben aber würde dann länder
seit ich die möglichkeit bestehen ab
turniers zehnten und zwar ins events
unabhängig dass die länder für den
innenraum einer massen pflicht einführen
also nur dass es jeder versteht es ist
eine möglichkeit die ab dem ersten
szenen besteht die inzidenz
eigentlich keine rolle denn da könnte
das machen ganz unabhängig von der
intelligenz müssen sie es dann machen
lassen müssen es nicht machen längst
aber machen dann müssen sie eine
ausnahme vor sind für die innen rein wo
das masken tragen ersetzt werden kann
durch entweder einen impfausweis
verlesen aus was fläche testung
dank an die macht sich auch oben und das
ist die regelung die wir eingeführt
haben um es den ländern zu ermöglichen
wenn fast sagen jetzt nicht ganz so hoch
sind dass trotzdem schon die masken sich
im innenraum kommt man aber in der
masken pflicht also einfach die ein paar
ausnahmeregelung kurse zum beispiel in
der gastronomie jetzt kann man sich
fragen macht so etwas denn dann sind es
denn da nicht sinnvoll sofort die masken
pflicht für alle einzuführen ohne jede
ausnahme ohne und das ist medizinisch
also ist das eben kann es sinnvoll
solche ausnahmen zu machen wird nicht so
kann das sinnvoll sein wenn jemand in
einer gastwirtschaft und ezb geht mit
der maske rein das nicht geimpftes nicht
getestet und dann die maske ab setzt
dann dort eine stunde ohne also masken
weil er speist dann kann das weniger
sicher sein als wenn er vorher richtung
im ausweis gezeigt hat geht dann zwar
ohne maske vom tisch sitzt dann auch
ohne maske dabei war immer schon gegeben
somit kann fest obwohl das nicht für den
laien sofort plausibel ist kann es im
ressort sogar eine zusätzliche
sicherheit wenn wir kämpfen dort sitzen
und frisch gelesenen als leute die weder
gelesen noch sind aber die maske
angehabt haben wenn sie zum tisch gehen
und das ist sehr schwierig man muss dann
immer sagen man erklären dass das ja
hier zusammen dafür bedanke ich mich
auch aber das ist eine möglichkeit hier
mehr sicherheit anzubieten das ist also
der hintergrund das setzen des ganzen
und also jetzt ihr gibt es zwei
argumente die da immer wieder betont
werden müssen war das arge mängel sind
die werden zum teil auch vorgebracht
gegen diese regelung auch von denjenigen
die die regelung nicht mächtig das erste
argument ist dass das bedeutet doch man
muss sich dann drei alle drei monaten
impfen lassen das natürlich nicht so für
die drei monate gehen wir davon aus dass
dann der schutz vor infektionen geht
aber die impfungen wirken natürlich viel
länger und die impf wirkung und auch die
sommer der impfausweis das von den drei
monaten ja gar nicht berührt somit wäre
es nicht so dass dann alle drei monate
werden
jetzt wollen auch gar nicht vorgesehen
sondern das ist die dauer wir glauben
dass die neuen impfungen auch vor
ansteckung schützen
also nicht nur verschwörung verlauf
sondern auch veranstaltung wenn sich die
studie zu entwickeln dass das länger das
sagen mit neuen impfungen länger als
drei monate vor ansteckung schützen dann
würden wir diesen zeitraum um drei
monate verlängert dann würde das ganze
vier motoren fünf monate die das kann
dann verlängert werden das steht im
gesetz auf drängen der normentwurf somit
die drei monate sind erst mal unsere
schätzung auf der grundlage der daten
die wir haben dass man für drei monate
auch der ansteckung geschützt
schwerem verlauf dass man viel länger
geschützt aber dass man für drei monate
hat dann quasi im ersatz einer maske
weil man wahrscheinlich vor ansteckung
geschützt ist die massen bestrafen muss
das ist die logik dieses also dieser
vorwurf ist also es hat nichts damit zu
tun die impfung gilt nur für drei monate
das hat nichts damit zu tun dass man
sich alle drei monate irgendwann lassen
muss ist einfach nur von dem was wir
bisher wissen dass man für drei monate
auf bahnstrecken
ein zweiter punkt und der wird immer
vorgetragen er ist auch nicht also
unbegründet kühlen kann man aber in den
griff bekommen und zwar ist das denn zu
komplizieren also können dann
beispielsweise die restaurants
erschaffen was die wenn die man
reinkommen tatsächlich prüfen hat der
frächter irgendwas getestet ist der
chinesin schaffen die antwortet sie
haben es auch in der vergangenheit
geschafft haben auch bei 3 gegen klose
so haben wir ja diese prüfungen sind
betroffen sind ja gelernt sie werden nur
jetzt einfach wie werden die
verantwortung einfach indem einfach
schlicht mehr gas für alle drei
merkmalen die es da gibt also eine grüne
farbe dann auf den zertifikaten
also man muss sich das wie folgt
vorstand sehen sie ja klar zertifikate
wenn das jetzt noch ein 3 monats das
wäre was bei mir jetzt aber wenn das
noch ein 3 monats das wären oder einer
drei monats gerechnet also
bestätigung oder ein
test von also gestern dann werden wir
jetzt immer eine grüne habe so dass man
beim reinkommen das ähnlich sagen kann
zeigt die c b a und schon ist die
kontrolle möglich es wird aus four getan
erwiesen an dass denn dann drinnen
kontrollieren stichprobenweise wenn die
leute rein gekommen sind wie geht das da
kann man immer wirklich nicht bogen
machen da kann man sagen können sie mir
noch gerade noch einmal ihren
festzeitung der grünen co grünes also
ihren grünen nach fast wäre das auch
drinnen relativ einfach kontrollieren
wie gesagt wir werden das mit den
ländern gesprächen das ist nicht in
stein gegossen
nächste woche werden wir mit den leitern
der staatskanzleien darüber lange
diskutieren aber ich halte das also für
umsetzbar und auch eine möglichkeit im
einstieg also in den herbst also
tatsächlich klarzukommen letzter punkt
zu dieser ersten stufe rechne ich denn
damit dass die länder das überhaupt alle
machen werden zum ersten zehnten oder
wird das ein flickenteppich werden waren
die länder vielleicht diese regelung gar
nicht ich glaube dass lernen dass alle
machen werden weil ich davon ausgehe
dass wir zum ersten zehnter wieder
höhere fallzahlen haben dann müssen die
länder reagieren von daher glaube ich
dass diese regelung zum tag und ganz
kurz noch zu dieser zweiten stufe da
geht es um höhere instanzen das ist so
eine mischung kritische infrastruktur
ist bedroht in fünf hinter sich
stationen sind also in überlastung
möglicherweise schon die haben mehr tote
meer schwere fälle dann kommen
zusätzliche also reden kommen die gene
konzepte die vorgegeben sind dann fallen
die ausnahmen für die masken pflichten
im innenraum weg und dann müssen masken
mit schals auch draußen getragen werden
in den veranstaltungen wo man sonst die
abstände nicht einhalten kann es kommt
auch zu mit mindestabständen und es
kommt zu obergrenzen sehr wichtig zu
obergrenzen in den innenräumen weil die
innenräume können so über die
obergrenzen sicher gemacht werden wie
sage ich ja höher die fasern werden dass
du konservativer werden die obergrenze
sein und somit also werden dann immer
weniger leute sich in den innenräumen
und gleichzeitig aushalten können um
also der
steigenden fahrzeug zu bewegen zu
begegnen ist uns also zwei punkte dich
noch mal hervorheben wird zum einen
deshalb gibt es keine grenzwerte einige
länder haben dass sein kollege holt zum
beispiel wieso keine kleinen zwerg ist
und ich so und so viele unter uns weiter
naja das ist einfach für die gerichte
aber auch für die nutzung dieser
möglichkeiten sehr viel besser werden
man die gesamtstruktur der gefährdung
gedenkt die gesamtstruktur der bewertung
zum beispiel damals bei der fahrer die
fahrt zum beispiel sehr von davon ab wie
viele fälle werden denn überhaupt
getestet wenn ist eine riesige
dunkelziffer habe ist die pfalz hat
vielleicht nicht der aus landesfest
berechtigt oder beispielsweise vater ist
es nicht sinnvoll dann gleichzeitig auch
auch die abwasser kontrolle zu schauen
weil die abwasser kontrolle läuft auch
den steigenden fallzahlen
voraus das kann man dann mit bedenken
oder beispielsweise bei der
intensivstationen cook wie viele leute
liegen auf der intensivstation
das hängt sehr davon ab was das
gefährdet sind wenn es zum beispiel
schwere fälle sind die lange dort liegen
dann weiß aus denen sich das unendlich
lange nicht leeren wenn das aber noch
fälle sind die von operationen und her
stammen dann ist es in der regel so die
leute nicht wenige tage auf der
intensivstation das liest sich dann so
schnell wieder und somit also muss man
immer mitdenken da ist es rechts fester
hier mit einer beschreibung der gefahr
zu operieren hat dass man lexikon
grafisch versucht von sieben oder acht
parametern an sozusagen gesamtscore zu
bilden das klappt in der regel nicht
dass nacht auch kein land wirklich
erfolgreich und die beschreibung der
gefahr mit den parametern die wir haben
da wird ja viel genauer sein als was wir
hatten das ist aus meiner sicht dass
viel besser grundlage als der immer
wieder gescheiterten versuch mit also
grenzwerten dort zu arbeiten trotzdem
werden was in den ländern noch einmal
anhören wenn die länder haben diese
kritik schwung verzögert haben und wir
werden dann sicherlich also in der
nächsten woche auch beispiele von den
ländern ließen sich das gerät vorstellen
wir sind nicht in der lage gewesen und
so etwas genauer vorzustellen wie soll
so ganz werte aussehen aber wenn die
länder uns da in der nächsten woche also
informieren wollen ganz aktuell sehr
dankbar und also das
zweite kritikpunkt ja also das sagen wir
nicht kritikpunkt sondern sagen hat die
zweite frage spielen denn dann überhaupt
tote schwere fälle eine rolle geht es
nur darum kritische infrastrukturen
spiel es geht und aller erster linie
immer um schwere fälle tote zu
verhindern long kurve zu verhindern und
da steht auch also in dem norm texte
darin also unter dem punkt sechs ländern
in der neuen text aso vorliegt bei der
begründung der zweiten stufe steht
ausdrücklich dass es darum gehen muss
auch schwere fälle und sterbefälle zu
verhindern und also die überlastung der
kritischen infrastruktur oder der
kliniken ist ja nur ein mittel dafür
also schwere fälle und tote zu
verhindern dass er kein selbstzweck
sondern das ist ein mittel dafür und
daher haben wir dies also damit das klar
ist aber dass auch noch mal in dem text
aufgenommen und der arabisch 6 zu beginn
der zweiten stufe uns mit der begründung
noch mal eine rolle spielen
herzlake lauterbach rasanter bitteschön
guten morgen ich möchte mal beginnen mit
so ein bisschen
eindrücken und stimmungs gehe ich jetzt
aus dem sommer
wenn man wenn man sich die vergangenen
beiden jahre ansieht dann hatten wir im
sommer sehr sehr niedrigen zinsen
teilweise im zweistelligen bereich und
wirklich eine wirkliche entspannung auch
im gesundheitswesen auch im öffentlichen
leben und meiner erinnerung nach
verschwand das thema kur wird auch aus
sozusagen aus der öffentlichen
diskussion
und und das war irgendwann sagten es
diesen sommer ja eben nicht so wir haben
wir kennen eine saisonalität von corona
wären die verstärkte infektionen machen
im winter das natürlich auch damit zu
tun wo man sich aufhält und so weiter
aber wir haben dieses jahr eine richtig
ausgeprägte sommer cups hat minister
auch gerade noch einmal dargelegt zum
glück ist die jetzt am abklingen das hat
vor allen dingen mit der sogenannten b
85 variante der der omicron variante zu
tun und diese variante ist sehr sehr
stark übertragbar sie entweicht nochmal
der immunantwort und leider ist es auch
so dass 75 variant ihre eigenschaften
der gestalt noch mal verändert hat dass
sie wieder etwas besser auch die tiefen
abschnitte der lunge infizieren kann und
der der unterschied im wesentlichen zu
den vorherigen omikron varianten ist
tatsächlich dass er wieder etwas mehr
patienten auch auf unseren stationen
gesehen haben die eine lungenentzündung
haben das ganze hat jetzt nicht zu einer
überlastung des systems geführt aber ich
kann ihnen sagen dann zeitweise wirklich
auch nach betten gesucht hat eine volle
kurbelt normalstation auch auf den
intensivstationen da wieder etwas mehr
betrieb so etwas kannten wir aus den
letzten sommern gar nicht der
unterschied dieser infektionswelle zu
infektionswellen die wir aus den letzten
jahren kennen ist ja dass die relative
krankheitslast also die zahl der
schweren erkrankungen und todesfälle
gemessen an der gesamtzahl der
infektionen
dies natürlich deutlich geringer als zum
beispiel der del-tabelle oder eine alpha
beladen und der grund dafür ist dass wir
einen hohen immunisierung grad in der
bevölkerung haben der nimmt auch weiter
zunimmt mit infektionen zu den mit
schimpf und der führt eben dazu das
obwohl sehr viele reaktionen da sind
nicht mehr ganz so viele leute schwer
krank werden aber was auch eine falschen
darstellung ist meines erachtens ist das
überhaupt niemand mehr krank wird muss
ich ihnen 1000 klinikalltags schildern
das spielt so auch nicht risikopersonen
oder auch andere ungünstige
konstellation können schon auch dazu
führen dass mit diesen neuen varianten
auch mal wieder leute krank werden in
der einfach gemessen an dieser sehr
hohen zahl der infektionen ist immer
noch wenig aber in absoluten zahlen sind
dann trotzdem patienten die versorgt
werden müssen
noch gravierender ist aber das problem
natürlich auch im bereich des personals
da haben wir erhebliche personalausfälle
jetzt mitten im sommer gehabt und auch
das kennt man aus den krankenhäusern
eigentlich nicht im sommer haben wir in
der regel weniger patienten und einen
niedrigen krankenstand und da haben wir
teilweise einen sehr hohen krankenstand
gehabt und wir haben auch sehr viel
betrieb auch in den notaufnahmen das
kann man in diesem register
notaufnahme registern und ähnlichem auch
ganz gut nachvollziehen das ist also
eigentlich dieses sommerloch was wir
eigentlich kennen wo dann ein bisschen
verschnaufpause auch ist in den
rettungsstellen das haben wir in dem
sinne dieses jahr nicht gehabt
geschuldet der sommer welle und
natürlich auch schon sagen jedenfalls
den personal steckt natürlich auch zu
einer gala pandemie mit hoher belastung
in den knochen da ist sicherlich die
belastungsgrenze jetzt auch teilweise
erreicht gewesen so dass wir in diesem
bereich diesem sommer auch schon
belastungssituationen hatten was für ein
sommer ungewöhnlich ist und wenn man
jetzt den blick richtung herbst richtet
ist es schon auch ein wahrzeichen bei
mir normalerweise auf einem sehr
niedrigen niveau starten im sommer und
dann höheren krankenstand oder eine
höhere krankheitslast bekommen wie
gesagt
aktuell klingt er die sommer welle
wieder ab das ist auch gut so
und mein eindruck ist dass das in der
bevölkerung auch öffentlichkeit man
eigentlich so ein bisschen auch die
möglichkeit vielleicht sogar eine
gleichgültigkeit gegenüber dem thema
hier und da nimmt ich kann das
nachvollziehen weil letzten endes viele
leute auch selber vielleicht schon
fixiert waren das thema erkennen und man
im grunde jetzt am öffentlichen leben
auch kaum beschränkungen hat mit wenigen
ausnahmen wo masken zum beispiel zügen
getragen werden müssen ist das normale
leben eigentlich wieder normal ab und
das denke ich ist gut so
aber man sich natürlich infektionen im
privaten wie im beruflichen umfeld und
letzten endes müssen wir aber natürlich
im hinterkopf schon den blick etwas
richten auch die wintermonate das
betrifft natürlich viele bereiche aber
insbesondere jetzt auch noch mal das
gesundheitswesen und die kritische
infrastruktur und ja die
krankheitsfolgen franco wird 19
und deswegen hatten wir mit dem
expertenrat der bundesregierung vor ein
paar wochen auch schon an dieser stelle
ein ein konzeptpapier vorgestellt in
denen wir
bestimmte szenarien skizziert haben die
wir relativ grob in drei verschiedene
kategorien eingeteilt hatten dass eine
wer ein günstiges szenario es kommt auf
einmal eine variante die sich durchsetzt
die macht überhaupt nicht mehr krank
oder nur noch sehr wenig leute krank und
immunisiert im grunde die bevölkerung
und wir müssen kaum maßnahmen ergreifen
wir einfach trotzdem keine personen in
den krankenhäusern kommen und es kommt
zu arbeitsausfällen kommt das war dass
günstiges szenario dann gibt es ein
basisszenario was ich so aus dieser pa 5
variante diesem bild was wir jetzt sehen
eigentlich heraus entwickelt und ich
glaube aktuell ist nicht prognose dass
möglicherweise dieses basisszenario in
welcher ausprägung auch immer so im
herbst eines sein könnte mit dem was
auseinandersetzen müssen an diesem
szenario mehr schon vorgesehen auch
wieder skizziert das ist hier auch
wieder durch die saisonalität durch
diese ganzen dinge die im winter
passieren durch zusätzliche
atemwegserkrankungen die wir im winter
sowieso immer haben dazu kommen kann
dass wir wieder zwei mehr personal aus
verlangen dass sie wieder mehr kranke
auf den stationen haben wir sehen jetzt
hier nicht zwangsweise eine überlastung
des systems vor aber etwas was dann doch
bestimmte maßnahmen vorsieht die man die
man ergreifen kann und zu diesen
maßnahmen gehören unter anderem das
tragen von masken innenräumen und
eventuell auch bestimmte ideen konzepte
und natürlich auch das thema impfung
spielte eine rolle und das thema
datenerhebung und und bestimmung von
krankheitslast und belastungsfaktoren im
system und viele dieser dinge finden
sich in dem entwurf der jetzt hier
vorgelegt wurde ja eigentlich auch
wieder
die die
[Musik]
dieses basisszenario
das hatten wir gestern das
skizziert vor dem hintergrund dass die
berg 5 wäre gerade kam jetzt haben wir
fünf die evolution von viren können wir
nicht wirklich vorhersagen die wird sich
aber weiter entwickeln das ist nicht das
ende sozusagen der fahnenstange und das
kann in beide richtungen gehen zum einen
kann das virus zusätzlichen mutationen
bekommen die ist noch einmal etwas
besser in die lage versetzen der imf
antwort auszuweichen auch das kennen wir
jetzt schon von gea fünf wichtig zum
beispiel wenn man vorher mit einer
anderen omikron variante infiziert war
dann geht nach drei monaten da dieser
schutz anscheinend auch schon wieder
deutlich zurück das sieht man so den
ersten daten die man sehen kann so dass
das virus natürlich sondern immer mittel
und wege sucht wieder interessieren zu
können und es kann aber da am rande
einer revolution eben auch passieren
lassen wir wo es entsteht was auch
wieder mehr krank macht wie zum beispiel
jetzt der fall ist das der r5 zeigen so
dänische daten dem etwas stärker krank
macht ohne dass wir jetzt irgendwas
vergleichbar der tabelle
zu den impfung ist es so dass wir oder
oder nochmal ein rückgriff nochmal auf
die maßnahme nicht ob die maßnahmen die
wir genannt hatten und die kirche die
auch geschildert wurden sind alles
maßnahmen die die wahrscheinlichkeit von
infektionen von schweren erkrankungen
von tod reduzieren ich glaube man muss
ein bisschen sowohl teurer machen oder
über über impfung redet von diesen
binären wegkommen das eine ist ein
kompletter schutz und das andere es
überhaupt keinen schutz ja also auch
über die vierte impfung über die wir
sprechen und das tragen von masken
reduziert ja die wahrscheinlichkeit
einer infektion und reduziert den
zufolge wahrscheinlich dass man schwer
krank oder verstirbt oder longo bild
bekommt aber die bringt das in der regel
nicht auf null solchen maßnahmen gibt es
in der medizin ganz selten und so ist es
eben jetzt auch insbesondere mit einem
virus zu tun hat was ich dass ich wieder
stärker verändert von daher finde ich es
gut diese maßnahmen so zu betrachten als
was sie sind die haben alle einen
beitrag wenn man sie kombiniert kriegt
man auch einen größeren effekt also
wenig dass unten maske trägt dann hat
das eben noch einen starken effekt der
letzte vierte impfung da gibt es eine
stiko empfehlung ich glaube die teilen
alle hier im raum gerade personen die
älter sind über 70 demnächst
möglicherweise über 60 die sollten sich
relativ zügig impfen lassen weil wir
eben viele infektionen haben das sind
die person die man auch noch in den
krankenhäusern sieht leute mit dem
wunsch welchen anderen erkrankungen
sollten das ohnehin machen irgendwo
personen können abwartend seien wir
haben gute nachrichten wird zu
angepassten impfstoffen die werden einen
vorteil bringen sie werden die antwort
noch mal verbreitern noch mal wieder
verstärken und die zur verfügung stehen
denke ich es ist ein sehr gutes angebot
bei möglicherweise auch für weitere
personengruppen die dann auch einen
effekt haben und das sehen wir auch in
studien noch mal der impfkampagne und
auch in modellberechnung kann dazu
führen dass auch die instanzen
runtergehen kann dazu führen oder oder
wird dazu einen effekt haben beitragen
können und natürlich eben auch die
belastung die wir sehen in der
kritischen infrastrukturen im
gesundheitssystem und deswegen bleiben
eigentlich diese verschiedenen maßnahmen
wichtig nicht verweise in der
kombination je nachdem mit honda
variante bis zu tun haben wie stark die
infektion ansteigen dass sie ansteigen
werden das klar und und deswegen glaube
ich wir kennen die maßnahmen wir müssen
klug einsetzen und das adaptiert an die
jeweilige situation finden herzlichen
dank dann kommen wir zu fragen die es
erträgt buchstelle
[Musik]
vielen dank also so viel offenheit
häufig gar nicht andeuten im lagen bei
dem vorschlag den wir jetzt haben und
den vorschlag finde ich auch richtig
sonst hätte ich ihnen hier nicht
vorgetragen und verteidigt ich bin
einfach in erwartung dessen was die
länder dort also sind wir bringen werden
beispielsweise kann ja die kritik man
will konkrete also an will konkrete
schwellenwerte um die zweite stufe zu
fahren das glaube ich wird nicht
funktionieren aber wenn man so etwas
vorschlägt dann muss man auch ein
vorschlag bringen wie man sich das
vorstellen wurde ich hatte es nicht 14
wohl nicht bringen und zum zweiten ich
glaube auch nicht dass die länder uns
vorschlagen werden dass wir von tag eins
an erster zehnter oder so dann die
allgemeiner masken pflicht ausnahmslos
also einführen werden
somit also glaube ich würde es zum
schluss bei dem vorschlag den ich in
rage gebracht habe bleiben
war jetzt nur irritiert weil sie gerade
gesagt haben das eigentlich im stein
gemeißelt das gilt ja für jede sitzung
die wir mit den ländern haben das ist
also wir könnten uns ja dieses
wahlverfahren das verfahren ist ja noch
ein parlamentarisches verfahren und also
die länder müssen auch mit einbezogen
werden wir könnten uns das komplett
sparen wenn es klar wäre dass wir keine
änderungen also diskutieren wollten ich
bin einfach gespannt also was da kommt
ich glaube dass der vorschlag hand und
fuß hat dass er auch durchdachte es
genauso wie
sander eben sagte also wir versuchen mit
diesen methoden einfach schlicht
ergreifend die fallzahlen
runterzubringen und wenn wir die
fallzahlen runterbringen senken wir die
fallzahl von longo wild und senke die
schweren fälle lungenentzündungen und so
auch die todes werde somit das ist so
ein strauß von möglichkeiten die
fallzahlen runterzubringen und ich
glaube dass es gut funktionieren kann
das ist auf jeden fall also verankert in
dem das der expertenrat uns
dankenswerterweise zur verfügung
gestellt hatte wir haben uns sehr eng an
den empfehlungen des expertenrats auch
orientiert also was zum beispiel diese
frage angeht also gibt es eine maßen
aber die alles erschlägt oder gibt es
also ist es besser auf mehrere maßnahmen
gleichzeitig zu setzen das ist ja das
was sie was wir eben auch gehört haben
und dass man auch viele maßnahmen
gleichzeitig setzt um die fallzahl zu
begrenzen das haben wir verfolgt
ich wollte mal auf die vierte impfung zu
sprechen kommen das hat jetzt für sehr
turbulente
meinungsäußerungen besorgt also die idee
stiko ist recht aufgebracht bemerken
dass professor von kries
was sagen sie also weiß ja auch offenbar
auch draußen also draußen
bevölkerung gibt darüber was jetzt zu
tun und zu lassen ist also soll man
tatsächlich jetzt in diesem rhythmus die
vierte im zu machen sondern warten auf
den passenden impfstoff ich weiß dass
diese frage auch schon häufiger gestellt
wurde aber einfach zur klarstellung
vielleicht
ja also dazu zwei dinge ich hatte halt
also darauf hingewiesen dass derjenige
der jetzt also noch jünger ist dass er
wenn er sich impfen lassen will dass das
mit seinem hausarzt bespricht das war
durchgehend meine position das ist somit
keine impfempfehlung für alle jungen wo
ich das immer wieder also
vorgetragener ärger wenn ich sage wenn
sie jünger sind und wollen wissen ob
sie sich impfen lassen sollen dann
fragen sie ihren hausarzt dann ist es
kann entweder empfehlung für alle mal
der haushaltskasse sagt beispiel sagen
nein auf keinen fall wurde lauter als
kann sagen um gottes willen sie sind ja
so ein starker asthmatiker dann auf
jeden fall oder ganz sagen ja was machen
sie ein beruflicher sagen ich arbeite
hinter der theke im berghain also ich
habe es sehr gefährdet dann lassen sich
doch irgendwie so daraus kann eine menge
sagt daher war meine empfehlung und
dabei bleibe ich auch
dass man wenn man jünger ist dass man
sich mit einem seinem hausarzt abspricht
und dabei wären solche sachen dann mit
gedacht das ist aber dann noch keine
empfehlung für alle jungen und alles
andere also ist ehrlich gesagt auch der
versuch verwirrung zu stiften wo keiner
ist das ist einfach schlicht so und das
ist auch jetzt so die stiko empfehlung
ist eine empfehlung aber jeder es kann
natürlich also sich an der empfehlung
empfinden orientieren oder nicht ich
beispielsweise bin auch ein arzt und
wenn der stiko empfehlung bei der
impfung unter 60 nicht gefolgt sondern
habe eine fährte impfung also
genommen er war sehr viele kontakte aber
das war für mich der ausschlaggebende
grund der impfung war übrigens schon im
ersten dass ihre nächste frage wäre es
ist schon länger austreiben oder das
zurück sie wird offenbar jetzt nicht
mehr gut genug aber lange rede kurzer
sinn der einzel musste in
haushaltsfragen können also dass ich mit
jedem von oder nicht und ansonsten finde
ich sind die kämpfe lung und klar und
richtig und empfinden und bekommt auch
meine voller zustände also zustimmung
natürlich wir haben jetzt hier im die
grundsätzliche die generelle empfehlung
über 70 da wird an einer empfehlung was
ich weiß und für die über 60 jährigen
jetzt gearbeitet und was natürlich auch
klar ist es wird zu neuen empfehlungen
kommen wahrscheinlich werden die neuen
impfstoffe da sind weil die halten
empfehlungen werden die alte neben
stoffe und für die neuen stoffe dann
kommen wie eben beschrieben dann wird es
auch reichlich neue impfstoff ergeben
dass würdig mutmaßen noch ein kleiner
zusatz also das
jetzt oder warten auf dem dach
ich kann damit nur meine persönliche
position also vortragen wie gesagt also
das ist keine kleine persönliche
position der sache ist keine kritik an
der stiko damit das noch mal klar ist
ich würde all denjenigen die jetzt also
ein hohes risiko ein weil sie älter sind
oder begleiterkrankungen haben ihn würde
ich nicht raten zu warten weil wir am
nach wie vor hohe fallzahlen und es geht
ja bei älteren menschen darum schweren
verlauf oder tod zu verhindern und das
leisten die an zentralen impfstoffe sehr
gut ob dass die neuen impfstoffe besser
lasten das wissen wir nicht
wahrscheinlich wird was die schweren
verläufe tod schwerer verlauf bei den
älteren der jetzt bestehenden teams noch
alles bieten was wir brauchen da würde
ich da nicht warten wenn ich jetzt
selbst ein junger mensch wäre noch junge
aus ich bin dann würde ich mir schon
überlegen wenn ich das risiko chance
durch masco ein bisschen vorsicht
eindämmen könnte habe ich dann warte bis
die neuen impfstoffe da sind das ist
aber jetzt mal eine persönliche
einschätzung der lage um das noch mal zu
sagen weil es immer wieder medienwert
also konstruiert ja gerne duelle drosten
gegen streek lauterbach gegen märkten
dagegen und so weiter und ich möchte es
nicht als wirklich eine kritik an der
position der stiko
verstanden wissen sondern einfach meine
position im rahmen dessen was derzeit
auch praktiziert hat
nächste frage erhitzt
herr minister ich habe noch eine oder
mehrere fragen zum verständnis sie
sagten dass spiele für den impfpass
keine rolle die sache der
dreimonatigen impfungen sie haben ihre
hemmende hergezeigt wird denn dieses
nach drei monaten dann wieder rot wenn
es vorher grün war dann würde es ja doch
eine rolle spielen für den impfpass und
mädchen auch für den zugang und daraus
abgeleitet haben wir dann viele eben
konstruiert dass man sich dabei drei
monate nach hilfen müsste um diesen
grünen balken wieder zu bekommen können
sie das noch mit klären
bei den gerichten sagten sie ist sei
für die gerichte notwendig keine
grenzwerte einsatz der bayerische
gesundheitsminister sagt er gerade das
gegenteil der sagt das sei rechts fester
wenn man grenzwerte haben wie bringen
sie diesen widerspruch zusammen und an
herrn sander hätte ich die frage die
angepassten impfstoffe es gibt
äußerungen aus der medizin der welt die
sagen wenn man sich zu oft impft und
kein quasi krank machen das antigen also
mit damit nicht in kontakt kommt dass
die impfungen auch den gegenteiligen
effekt haben dass sie das immunsystem
sozusagen erlahmen lassen wird das durch
die angepassten impfstoffe wieder auf
null gestellt dieser effekt oder spielen
die weil das ebenfalls ein corona
impfstoff ist hier die gleiche rolle
herr fehlen dann zunächst einmal offen
gesagt
ganz ehrlich sein also ich bin jetzt
nicht ganz sicher ob sie das nicht also
ich erkläre es einfach noch mal also der
er drei monate lang nach der impfung
also ist der pass tannengrün weil man
davon ausgehen kann also dass sie vor
infektionen geschützt sind und danach
wird er wieder blau weil man da nicht
mehr davon ausgehen kann auf der
grundlage der derzeitigen studienlage
dass sie dann noch vor infektionen
geschützt sind und dann müssen sie
wieder mal ausgetragen so simpel ist das
und daraus folge aber nicht dass sie
sich dann um wieder in grün zeigen zu
können alle drei monate hin verlassen
sollen das wäre mir die zehn nicht
vollkommen unsinnig wahrscheinlich auch
keinen arzt ihnen anbieten und wird doch
wahrscheinlich niemand machen mal davon
ab was ich kann mich vorstellen dass ich
jemanden hat der im test nur um ohne
maske in restaurants gehen zu können das
kann ich mir kaum vor ich dann hoffe ich
wenigstens nicht und werden dann wäre es
an uns als ärzte das nicht so umzusetzen
dass es nur dann braucht man ja auch
einen arzt der bereit wäre alle drei
monate einen gesunden jungen menschen zu
impfen also die der also im grünen pass
haben will das glaube ich werde nicht
stattfinden sicherlich nicht in den
impfzentren
und die somit also ist die einzige was
also ja an unsicherheit noch ist wenn
sich jetzt zeigen
dass wir also impfstoff für die neuen
angepassten stoffe vor infektionen
länger schützen als drei monate daran
wird das intervall
verlängert anders ausgedrückt dann würde
das zertifikat zertifikaten länger grün
aufleuchtet später blau werden das
wissen wir aber noch nicht weil wir
diese daten zum jetzigen sagen wann ich
habe mir ist auch bekannt was kollege
jack aus bayern also sagt was er sich
hier vorgestellt was rechts fester wäre
und also hier gibt es aber zwei ganz
klare also
also im argumente die dagegen sprechen
zum einen das gesetz ist ja zusammen
erstellt worden mit dem
bundesjustizminister und der
bundesjustizminister burg mit seiner
fachlichkeit für diese aussage die ja ja
ähnlich wie ich sie jetzt hier tätigen
auch in bezug auf ihnen immer wieder
also gemacht hat er hat ja immer wieder
darauf hingewiesen dass eine solche
regelung vor gericht rechts fester ins
und immer wieder kompliziert dann das
beispiel aus dem polizeirecht gebracht
was er so oft gebracht hat dass ich es
ihnen jetzt selbst vortragen könnte was
ich aber nicht tun der zweite punkt ist
der also wenn man sich anschaut was ist
denn in der vergangenheit vor gerichten
also also sag mal was hat bestand gehabt
die allermeisten regeln die vor gericht
gelandet sind die länder gemacht haben
sind zum schluss durch die berichte
bestätigt worden das ist ja nicht so
dass es meist nicht bestätigt wurde
sondern fast alles ist vor gericht
bestätigt worden oder sehr viel sogar so
zumindest und das waren also fast immer
regelungen die sich nicht festgemacht
haben an bestimmten grenze werden und
daher glaube ich in der summe wenn man
sich auf die also arten gerichtsurteile
noch einmal konzentriert
und zum zweiten wenn man der logik des
justizministers hier folgt sind wir hier
im rechtssicheren bereich
ja vielen dank für die frage also dieses
diese these dass wiederholte impfungen
dazu führen dass das immunsystem erlahmt
die wird in unterschiedlicher
sozusagen unterschiedlicher couleur
immer mal wieder vorgetragen das ist
aber das ist nicht durch daten gestützt
die aktuellen daten aus eigentlich allen
untersuchungen sei es im logischen
untersuchungen oder noch viel wichtiger
epidemiologische untersuchungen aus
israel zeigen dass die erneuten impfung
sei es die dritte impfung ja
sehr gut belegt ist dass sie wirklich
einen großen vorteil bietet insbesondere
auch schutz vor omikron infektionen und
erkrankungen
aber auch die vierte impfung dass sie
dazu führt weniger menschen stecken sich
an weniger menschen erkrankten weniger
menschen versterben insofern ist in
damit im prinzip dieses argument schon
in kräfte dass das immunsystem erlahmt
wenn daraus resultiert dass letzten
endes mehr menschen geschützt sind und
da gibt es ganz ganz große
untersuchungen aus israel zum beispiel
dass er sehr gut analysieren können und
auch unlogisch das haben wir selber
gemacht sieht man eigentlich dass ich
mit jeder impfung doch der immunschutz
doch noch ein bisschen verbreitet hat
auch noch ein bisschen verstärkt also
diese sorge die man aus vielleicht die
experimentellen untersuchungen als
geologe haben kann und die man auch
fündig berechtigterweise mal vortragen
kann die bestätigt sich zum glück in den
studien und in den daten nicht die
vierte impfung bringt einen vorteil sie
bringt bei älteren menschen ein hohes
risiko haben einen deutlich größeren vor
teilweise eben ohnehin ein großes risiko
haben dieses mit der dritten impfung
aber schon deutlich reduzierte risiko
reduziert sich nochmal weiter und bei
den jüngeren menschen ist es so dass sie
mit der dritten impfung ohnehin schon
sehr sehr gut geschützt sind und dass
der effekt der das risiko einer schweren
erkrankung noch mal zu reduzieren mit
einer vierten info aktuell sich in
studien statistisch nicht so richtig
darstellen lässt weshalb deren effekt
darauf haben ob man sich nochmal
transient schützt vor ansteckung und
deswegen ist es eben auch schließe ich
mich da auch den minister an schließlich
auch der stiko empfehlung an junge
menschen können aus individuellen
überlegungen das machen ich würde davon
nicht aktiv abraten aber ich würde das
jetzt auch nicht empfehlen vielleicht zu
diesem punkt ich möchte ich möchte dann
kollegin sandra nicht nur recht geben
sondern möchte auch auf eine gruppe
hinweis in dem logisch ganz gut
untersucht hat nämlich diejenigen die
deutlich mehr impfungen benötigen damit
die im film dargestellt werden kann also
leukämie erkrankte zum beispiel
bestimmte krebserkrankungen
autoimmunerkrankungen dort wird ja mit
mehr impfungen gearbeitet da sind einige
jetzt schon bei der siebten achten
impfung die wären natürlich sehr genau
überwacht weil wir da sicher sein wollen
dass wir nicht hineinschauen
hineinkommen auch dort haben sich diese
also theoretischen also meines wissens
nur im tierexperiment also beobachteten
das jetzt mal so gefahren durch viele
sind diese gefahren haben sich dort auch
nicht bestätigt
die nächste frage frau kollegin vorne
anderen hatte ich vom nachrichtenportal
watson erlaubt aber man sagt ja immer
dass man aus fehlern lernen kann oder
soll wenn sie einmal ganz konkret sagen
welche fehler wurden im umgang mit
jugendlichen in der pandemie gemacht und
was haben sie persönlich daraus gelernt
das ist
schwer zu sagen ich glaube dass man also
im eigenen fehlern also analysieren
sollte wenn also mehr zeit vergangen ist
so dass man sagen wir die lange strecke
sehen kann also wie hat sich das
ausgewirkt und
fehler also
andere kolleginnen und kollegen die
möchte ich nicht analysieren somit ich
bitte um verständnis ich glaube dass wir
hier also allesamt versuchen sehr eng an
wissenschaftlich gesicherten die politik
auszurichten das ist ja auch ein
experiment thema so wie wir haben
zumindest seit beginn meiner amtszeit
haben wir den austausch mit
wissenschaftlern sehr intensiviert also
ich glaube ich mich neben dem
expertenrat sehr intensiv auch mit
wissenschaftlern in deutschland und im
ausland aus also wenn man so will
markenzeichen meine arbeit gehen daher
auch mit herrn sander unabhängig von
seiner tätigkeit also im expertenrat im
ausland ständig fragen habe das geht für
viele andere die schon gesessen haben
das gilt für internationale
wissenschaftler und also ich glaube wir
bemühen uns wirklich das
wissenschaftlich gesicherte so gut wir
können umzusetzen
sie haben eben gerade schon
die medien kritisiert dass immer schön
ein gegeneinander konstruiert wird ich
würde mich da ganz gern mal anschließen
sieben punkte plan den sie vorgestellt
haben mit ihrem kollegen buschmann
klingt ja nach sehr vielen
zugeständnissen die sie gemacht haben
wie genervt sind sie denn davon dass
herr buschmann oder allgemein die fdp
ihn immer wieder in die quere kommt
zunächst in sieben und punkte plan habe
ich ohne abstimmung sogar mitten durch
man also vorbereitet weil er seine reine
bmg leistung denn nur der siebte punkt
also der
infektionsschutzgesetz punkt das ist ein
punkt den wir den ich quasi mit einem
buschmann abstimmen muss war der daten
unmittelbar mit zuständig ist also weil
die rechtlichen sora medikationen die
wir gerade noch also hier diskutiert
haben der kollege vorhin die müssen
natürlich mit dem minister abgestimmt
werden und da ist ein erster linie für
mich der justizminister nicht also
der vertreter der fdp aber die anderen
punkt die anderen sieben punkte die sie
damit also der fdp nichts zu tun sind
auch da nicht also diskutiert worden
beispielsweise dass wir in den
pflegeeinrichtungen einen besseren
hygiene schutz haben wurden an dax of it
beauftragten oder dass wir dort also
eine hilfe auftakt machen das wachstum
wird demnächst dispensiert werden darf
durch also ärzte und dass es gelagert
werden darf in pflegeeinrichtungen dann
nicht in der apotheke ausschließlich und
so hat all diese dinge auch ihre
pandemie radar der jetzt kommt mit dem
abwasser man so ja das sind erstens
dinge die mit der fdp gar nichts zu tun
haben geschweige denn mit herrn bush
machen und zum zarten das sehe ich auch
nicht dass ich irgendwelche
zugeständnisse machen musste an wen auch
immer
die nächste frage stellen verbaut
ja eine frage an sie beide ich frag mich
seit längerem in bezug auf die stiko
diese probleme in der politik also mit
politik mit der politik gibt es ja nicht
erst seit heute die gab es ja auch schon
mit herrn sparen ich frage mich warum
man es nicht schafft eine regelung zu
finden entweder eine neues gremium zu
schaffen oder die stiko aufzurüsten an
sie beide was ist da geplant und auch
ein sia sander sehen sie da eine
notwendigkeit und noch eine weitere
frage wenn es an sie herr lauterbach
nochmal zu der 3 monats regel sie sagen
ja man soll sich jetzt nicht alle drei
monate impfen lassen eine andere
möglichkeit wäre ja aber auch noch sich
testen zu lassen haben sie dann die
hoffnung dass man sich dann vielleicht
testen lässt wenn man dann eben nicht
mehr den grünen balken hat
ja viele national zustieg wo ich sage
noch einmal die stiko ist eine
großartige einrichtung mit der wir eng
zusammenarbeiten und die auch andere
hohe autorität den der deutschen
ärzteschaft hatten und dass gilt ist zu
schützen und nicht zu beschädigen
das ist ganz klar damit wir uns nicht
falsch verstehen und ich bin auch mit
herrn mertens also im bilateralen den
guten bilateralen austausch das muss ja
einfach gesagt sein man kann in der
sache schon mal also anderer meinung
sein aber das darf nicht darüber hinaus
dass nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass
man so eine stiko braucht wir haben die
stiko jetzt im einvernehmen mit herren
also merken so ein bisschen während ein
bisschen umbauen dass es da noch eine in
der stiko eine sogenannte pico gibt es
eine arbeitsgruppe dann in der stadt wo
die sich also mit pandemie also pandemie
kontrolle beschäftigt in kommissionen
palko und da werden dann noch ein paar
also externe also wissenschaftler hinzu
kommen die die stiko in der hinsicht
also noch noch stärker machen
unterstützen da wird es in kürze
ankündigungen von der stiko aufgeben ich
werde auch selbst noch enger mit der
stiko zusammenarbeiten indem ich mir zum
beispiel von dieser park noch
regelmäßiger auch berichten lassen sich
werden also quasi an den treffen der
pico werde ich möglicherweise auch
teilnehmen uns eigentlich dass beim
expertenrat jetzt auch machen so dass
ich noch besser verstehe also wie die
stiko intern diskutiert das sind alles
verbesserungen die aber einvernehmlich
jetzt geschlossen worden sind und somit
gilt die qs bewährt wir bekommen gute
empfehlungen und die gute arbeit wird
noch steht noch wird noch besser hin
ja ich kann mich dem anschließender sich
nico
ist ein gremium wasser sehr
evidenzbasiert arbeitet und auch
basierend auf evidence empfehlungen
abgibt um impfentscheidung letzten dies
zu erleichtern
für individuen und auch für die
ärzteschaft und hat deswegen auch eben
diese hohe akzeptanz und das wird sehr
sehr gut vorbereitet durch durch
hervorragende epidemiologen und
statistik und so weiter die reben die
vielzahl an studien die er existiert
nebeneinander legt auswertet und dann
quasi daraus empfehlungen oder und
ableitet und wirklich zahlen auf den
tisch legt und das dass das müssen wir
in der tat wirklich schützen und und und
in der tat hat uns das ja auch in der
pandemie sehr viel geholfen dass jedes
gremium
das das man in jedem gremium und das
sehen wir auch im eigenen betrieb immer
mal wieder angucken muss auch prozesse
verbessert werden können ich glaube das
ist steht außer frage und eine pandemie
ist ja auch eine sondersituation und
deswegen
zum beispiel einrichtung einer
arbeitsgruppe oder andere dinge das kann
man ja dann immer noch mal machen aber
im grundsatz ist das alles extrem
wertvoll und und hat uns glaube ich
extrem gut geholfen und hat die
akzeptanz in der ärzteschaft und in der
bevölkerung glaube ich deutlich erhöht
wichtig ist glaube ich auch
obwohl natürlich informationsfluss
sowohl in die politik und der
bevölkerung total wichtig ist muss
dieses gremium
unabhängig und auch vertraulich beraten
können weil manchmal werden natürlich
auch kontroverse fragen diskutiert und
das muss eben auch gehen in der
wissenschaftlichen beratung muss man
sich da offen und vertraulich
austauschen können ohne dass das
öffentlich breitgetreten wird oder dann
kommentiert wird und ich glaube so ist
das so hat die stiko bisher gearbeitet
und wird auch weiterhin arbeiten und und
es sind als solche dann wirklich ein
sehr sehr wertvolles gremium ich
antworte vielleicht ganz kurz zu ihrer
frage noch noch mit den tests ich kann
das nur wiederholen jede dieser
maßnahmen reduziert zu einem gewissen
grad die wahrscheinlichkeit infiziert zu
sein oder dann auch andere zu infizieren
und wenn man diese maßnahmen kombiniert
ist es noch besser wenn sie frisch
geimpft sind und sich zusätzlich
getestet haben oder konsequent eine
maske tragen und zusätzlich testen haben
sie einen höheren sicherheitsgrad finden
nur eins davon war gar nichts davon
machen und da kann ich immer nur an die
eigenverantwortung auch mit appellieren
weil die kombination das steht jedem
frei das zu machen und damit auch
infektionen weiter zu reduzieren
daher würden sie da auch noch mal
vielleicht ein bisschen ausführen ob das
eine auch im hintergrund war
dass die leute sich eher testen lassen
dann
also es wird ja so
sein dass der ein oder andere jüngere
mensch sich möglicherweise nicht für die
vierte impfung entscheidet das also kann
ja durchaus also die folge sein und dann
ist natürlich also hier der test von
großer bedeutung das ist ja auch einer
der gründe wieso habe ich für die
weiterführung der bürger test so lange
nicht eingesetzt habe und auch gekämpft
habe
diese möglichkeiten muss bestehen und
dann wäre es beispielsweise mit einem
frischen test bringen wir mal so ein
beispiel die zahlen wären danach das
also diese erste stufe gezündet wurde
die also ausnahmeregelungen gelten
ein junger mensch will in einen club
gehen will sich aber nicht ein viertes
mal impfen lassen oder vielleicht sogar
ein drittes mal impfen lassen wenn es
war magris dann kann er durch den test
trotzdem in den globalen und das ist
keine schlechte regelung in dem sinne
von daher dieser gleichklang genau mehr
sein dass eben gesagt hat dass wir mit
den drei möglichkeiten das wäre gewesen
die impfte und testete nebeneinander
haben damit gebe ich ein anreiz dass man
sich testen lässt und ich gebe aber auch
einen anreiz für diejenigen wo die
impfung in frage kommt dass sie sich
impfen lassen das können keine
schlechten an rad zu sein also es kann
kein schlechter an ratsam in einer
früheren phase der herbst und winter
pandemie dass sich dann viele menschen
testen lassen oder impfen lassen weil
das begrenzt dann quasi den anstieg der
zahl und wir kommen ja nicht in dieser
band hinein das ist diese medikation die
wir verfolgen wir sind ja nicht in den
endemischen status angekommen das war
nicht möglich weil die bafin variante
macht es nicht möglich wir sind also in
der medikation
das heißt wir müssen versuchen die
fallzahlen mit regeln die so wenig
zweimal störend sind wie
möglich aber doch wirken müssen wir
versuchen die fallzahlen doch relativ
niedrig zu halten weil wir sonst mit
vielen fällen von longo wird bei den
jüngeren rechnen müssen und mit schweren
verläufen bei den älteren der sauna des
gerade noch mehr ausgeführt bh 5
verläuft leider was die also pneumonie
angeht wieder etwas also gefährlicher
als baa1 auf ba2 und andere varianten
sind ja auch noch denkbar in dem sinne
von daher müsse bei den eltern diesen
schutz anbieten und bei den jüngern ist
das longo fit problem wirklich
bedenklich
also es gibt derzeit auf der grundlage
einer guten zusammenstellung also in
nature gibt es etwa 30 so größere
studien also man versucht also an
therapiekonzepte schon coviello wird
also zum erfolg zu bringen
aber zum jetzigen zeitpunkt sieht es
nicht wirklich gut aus also die konzepte
diebe unterwegs sind sind alle
epidemiologisch gesprochen er
weitschüsse da ist nichts dabei wo man
sagen würde das also wird wahrscheinlich
also es wird dass wir zu durchschlagen
daher müssen wir zeit gewinnen weil es
wird einfach etwas länger dauern bis wir
das logo wird problem gelöst haben
als man sich das am anfang vorgestellt
hat man darf nicht zu viele fälle zu
lassen war das hinterlässt dann doch
viele gerade jüngere menschen auch stark
eingeschränkt und auch nicht mehr also
also auch nicht mehr groß weg ist die
frage herr kollege
tauben ledigen mitteldeutsche rundfunk
herr lauterbach wie würden sie den
widerspruch erklären dass auf der einen
seite die konstruktion des
infektionsschutzgesetzes damit begründet
wird dass man sagen dass die länder ja
alle unterschiedliche gefahrenlagen
haben sie dann aber jetzt auch hier noch
mal wiederholen es ist wichtig dass sie
gehen davon aus dass alle länder jetzt
die verschärften maßnahmen ziehen werden
also warum macht man warum macht man es
dann so dass sie sehen also man sollte
die fragen der journalisten nicht
bewerten aber ich weiß was immer also
sehr zentrale wichtige frage haben warum
ich nicht lange nachgedacht werden also
im herbst an der lage finden dass es am
anfang so viele fälle gibt es wird
ausreichen dass man diesen sockel diese
sockel maßen aber überall ziehen sollte
das ist was ich glaube was passieren
wird werden also wir werden steigende
fallzahlen haben und gleichzeitig wieder
ein sockel von fällen der einfach zu
hoch ist und dann ist diese maßnahme hat
aus meiner sicht wahrscheinlich überall
sinnvoll so haben wir uns das überlegt
wenn das jetzt mehr hat dann eine sage
land hat mehr das andere hat weniger und
so weiter und so fort dann kommt diese
zweite stufe und dies dann von
bundesland zu bundesland kann man sagt
kommt die zu einem anderen zeitpunkt
aber meine also voraussage wäre die und
ich würde mich freuen wenn ich mich irre
was wir um den ersten zehnten herum in
einer situation gekommen sind wo alle
länder etwas machen müssen und dann
immer dass möglichst einheitlich machen
und das wäre dann das ergebnis
mit zusatz frage warum also jetzt hat
programm wenn ja auch gesagt man will
sich einigen unter den bundesländern
dass man gemeinsame regelungen findet
inwiefern findet eine abstimmung
abstimmung mit stadt und geben sie da
schon irgendwelche empfehlungen
es war für diese erste stufe ist
ja klar also werden die erste stufe
gezogen wird das ist dann immer ein all
or nothing
wenn also die erste stufe gezogen wird
jetzt zehnter es ist soweit dann ist
über drinnen maastricht arbeitsplatz das
restaurant alle öffentlichen räume und
es muss dann die ausnahmen geben das ist
dann schon einheitlich und daher ich
also kann das nur beschreiben also wie
es dann funktioniert das hat dann ein
relativ einheitliche spielt es sei denn
es gibt bundesländer die sagen bei uns
ist die inzidenz noch zu niedrig wir
machen das noch gar nicht dann gibt s
dann aber auch gar nicht aber werden es
etwas gibt dann gibt es das was ich
gerade beschrieben haben und was man
sich jetzt vorstellen könnte
beispielsweise dass die bundesländer
sich darauf einigen also alles war zum
teil die hier vorgetragen wurden für
diese zweite stufe dass sie dann sich
auf irgendwelche grenzwerte also
verständigen aber ich würde davon
abraten weil wir haben diesmal also wir
haben sehr sehr viele parameter die
beachtet werden müssen wir es so eine
tagesgenaue daten das wäre das aber
bisher nie gehabt wir haben tages genau
wieviel intensivbetten bewegte viele
freie
betten wie viele frei dann haben wir das
abwasser monitoring- dann haben wir die
sogenannten sentinel praxis sind diese
jungen praxen die wir auswerten dann
haben wir darüber hinaus die inzidenz
und wir haben die sterblichkeit und wir
haben darüber hinaus also die
hoffentlich wenigstens aber ich glaube
dass wir uns dem annähern können die
longo fit patientendaten aber das letzte
jeder neunte punkt der ist noch unsicher
die anderen acht daten und ich
persönlich kann ihnen sagen aus dass sie
aus acht unterschiedlichen daten nicht
irgendwie an einen score bilden können
der dann sagt abtasten daten gilt es in
dem sinne von daher glaube ich ist
dieser gedanke dass also wenn man so
viele gute daten hat dass man dann sich
auf einer das weil daten begrenzt ist
quantitativ asyl an zufall so ich glaube
dass es nicht funktionieren wird und wie
gesagt ich warte da ja auf die
vorschläge der nächste woche ich habe
noch keinen brauchbaren vor dass es
immer schnell gesagt also vieles ist ja
plausibel was man also in der politik so
hört vieles ist plausibel aber bei
näherem nachdenken dann falsch und das
ist so ein beispiel also erstmal
plausibel klingt lasst uns doch mal ein
paar zahlen nennen dann machen wir es
dann doch fest und so weiter aber dann
wenn man dann anfängt was sondern die
zahlen seien dann klingt es schon nicht
mehr so schlau
pauli von rtl ich habe zwei fragen herr
minister einmal gerade in der
urlaubszeit machen viele menschen die
erfahrungen wir fahren ins europäische
ausland und da ist corona fast gar kein
thema mehr auf masken pflicht wird nicht
so restriktiv gehandhabt
jetzt kommen sie mit neuen maßnahmen die
wieder verschärfung für die menschen
bedeuten was sagen sie denn jemanden der
sagt die anderen europäer die können
doch nicht auf dem holzweg sein und mit
zweite frage vielleicht an sie beide wir
haben gerade schon gehört wir sind viel
viel weiter was die erfahrungen mit
corona betrifft wir haben einen
angepassten impfstoff der bald verfügbar
ist wir haben sogar auch medikamente ab
wann wird man möglicherweise das ist ja
auch teil ihrer erwägungen sicherlich
mit corona umgehen können wie mit einer
ganz normalen erkrankung die
bedauerlicherweise auch menschenleben
fordern wird ohne dass das jetzt und wie
in der fragestellung zynisch klingen
soll
ja vielleicht dass ich ganz kurze
anfangen
die ja dass wir jetzt obwohl wir wenig
fett wenig fälle haben und im ausland
niemand etwas in kona hören will und in
deutschland die maßen auch das thema
eigentlich gar nicht jetzt hören wollen
das ist der preis dafür an den wir
zahlen müssen und dann auch ich zahlen
muss dafür dass wir im herbst besser
vorbereitet sein wollen also wenn ich in
den herbst vollkommen unvorbereitet
gehen wollte so wie letztes jahr
oder ja davor dann könnte ich sagen
gibt euch jetzt andere themen lassen sie
uns darüber dass gas sprechen oder und
so weiter und so fort aber ich muss
tatsächlich diese unangenehmen
diskussion über den herbst und masken
und so weiter die muss ich mitten im
sommer führen einfach weil ich
vorbereitet sein muss weil sonst bekomme
ich die gesetze nicht hin ich brauche am
24.08 den kabinettsbeschluss treiben
muss sich nächste woche mit den ländern
reden das ist einfach der preis dafür
wenn man besser vorbereitet will muss
man zu und das war ja auch einer der
gründe weshalb das in der vergangenheit
nicht geklappt hat war man im sommer
davon nichts hören wollte auch kein
politiker beschäftigt sich wie die leute
gerade gute laune haben und gehen zum
schwimmbad oder in den see kein
politiker beschäftigt sich mit diesen
themen dann öffentlich gern das ist ganz
klar dann schließe ich mich selbst mal
mit ein aber es ist einfach dafür werde
ich bezahlt
daher muss ich mit dem
sieben-punkte-programm nerven ich muss
die mit dem infektionsschutzgesetz muss
ich also nerven ich muss erklären und so
weiter weil sonst haben wir im herbst
die vorbereitung die wir immer hatten
nämlich keine und jetzt zu dem zweiten
punkt hier die
magie wird das laufen und so weiter er
hatte im rahmen meiner erkrankung hatte
ich also noch etwas mehr zeit zum lesen
als ich sonst haben dass also abgelenkt
vom wesen sehr stark ab und von daher
also habe ich also mich auch damit
beschäftigt wie viele varianten wird
denn dann noch geben ist das jetzt haben
wir den größten teil der neuen varianten
schon hinter uns also welche mutationen
sind noch denkbar das ist jetzt immer
harmlos da gibt es auch wissenschaftlich
sagen das ist so wie bei der erkältung
bald sind wir in der nähe der anderen
coronaviren lasst uns und wir konnten
wir waren ja schon mal bei baa1 das ist
jetzt noch mal ein kleiner rückschritt
also leider ist es nicht das ist leider
nicht so also es gibt noch sehr viele
varianten die also entstehen können also
dass mutations spektrum des virus ist es
ja kleines büro ist im vergleich zu
anderen wären also muss man sagen
gemessen an der zahl der gene diaz hat
ist es eigentlich klar aber also die
studienlage die es dazu gibt also zeigt
dass wir am anfang der möglichen also
mutationen sind das zeit auch über uns
dass die allermeisten wären eher
mutations potenzial nie ausschöpfen
niemals ausschöpfen das ist nur deshalb
ihr balkon also ebenso viele leute
infiziert sind und ein haupt- oder
wie sagt man auf deutsch also brutplatz
es sind hier menschen mit immundefekten
die sich infizieren und sehr lange das
virus in sich tragen zum beispiel acht
monate ein jahr und wo in dieser person
dann sehr viele mutanten entstehen also
in einer person geht heute davon aus
dass eine sehr große rolle die immun
komprimierten menschen sind die
infiziert sind wo das virus sich dann
weiterentwickelt über eine sehr lange
zeit das könnte sagen dass das anderen
auch um wichtige rolle spielt als
sozusagen die mutationen die entstehen
von personen zu personen ist auch noch
nicht ganz aus getestet aber dass in
diese richtung gehen die
wissenschaftlichen befunde wird michael
würde ich die position von jan sander
gleich interessieren aber trotzdem ist
es so daher ist nur dass zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt seriöserweise noch nicht sagen
wann wir zurück in der normalität sind
obwohl ich das immer wieder höre ich
wünschte das könnte man so abladen die
wahrheit ist aber wir können nicht
ausschliessen darauf hat ja auch der
expertenrat hingewiesen dass einer der
wohl mutationen die dann käme dass die
sehr ansteckend es aber gleichzeitig
auch wieder also von diesem rezeptor
profil was besteht was aber bestimmt wo
das virus im körper ansatz sagen ja mal
voraus tief in der lunge der er in
rachen oder was weiß ich dass das rezept
profil mit der ungünstiger wäre es kann
die man zum jetzigen zeitpunkt bestimmt
sagen
ja ich kann das gern noch kurz ergänzen
teil den andruck ich dass das im ausland
teilweise das thema weniger eine rolle
spielt ich finde auch in deutschland
sollen der öffentlichkeit zumindest beim
direkten umfeld spielt das thema auch
nicht wirklich so eine rolle gibt ja
viele themen und öffentlichen leben
glaube ich gibt es ja auch wenig
einschränkungen das finde ich auch
richtig so trotz der hohen fallzahlen
trotzdem ist es so dass die kogit 19
momentan eben nicht wie ein anderes
erkältungsvirus ist leider und warum ist
das so weil wir
erkältungsviren nie solche ausgeprägten
willen haben die dann parallel synchron
so viele leute krank machen die dann
eben ausfallen ich weiß es selber von
meinem arbeitsplatz charité wenn dann
auf einen schlag im zweistelligen
prozentbereich arbeitskräfte fehlen dann
haben sie schon eine erhebliche
einschränkungen das hat natürlich wieder
effekte auf die behandlung anderer
patienten die geist mit kurve zu tun
haben also das ist sicherlich ein effekt
den wir so von anderen art im mixer
regel nicht kennen die influenza oft
immer an einer grossen saisonalen welle
ab häufig ist die moderaten manchmal
kann sie sehr ausgeprägt sein aber das
kennt also das ist sozusagen noch
extraordinär an dem an dem krone virus
und es hat der minister ja gerade schon
gesagt die evolution dieses virus können
wir ja noch nicht vorhersagen das
springt noch ein wenig und es ist jetzt
nicht so dass es sich quasi
treppenförmig entwickelt wie wir das zum
beispiel bei influenza kennen das ist
immer noch ein kleines bisschen sich so
verändert dass es wieder infizieren kann
das kann teilweise große sprünge geben
und es kann natürlich wieder virus
eigenschaften verändern und das glaube
ich haben wir auch so ein bisschen
gelernt deswegen sind auch vom
expertenrat da etwas vorsichtiger wir
haben eben schon viele überraschungen
erlebt mit diesem virus ist ein neues
virus weiterhin und und deswegen glaube
ich kann man jetzt noch nicht das ganze
zu den akten legen und es behandeln wir
eine renovierung oder ein ganz
normales ein harmloses erkältungsvirus
was wir glaube ich aber glaube ich
vermitteln können die bevölkerung rein
das ist auch gut so dass man sehr viel
weniger angst und panik vor diesem virus
haben muss es gibt sehr wirksame
impfstoffe die fast sage ich mal das
risiko extrem senken dass man an diesem
virus verstirbt oder schwer erkrankt was
wir noch nicht richtig gut verstanden
haben es eben wie man auch wirklich
wirksam verhindert dass personen dieses
lankowitz syndrom entwickeln was was
sehr belastend und einschränkend sein
kann und wir haben gute medikamente auch
das kam zur sprache da gab es antikörper
medikamente geht es jetzt tabletten die
sollen jetzt besser und schneller
verteilt werden in israel zum beispiel
wurde das sehr sehr effektiv gemacht wir
haben sehr viel mit kollegen
ausgetauscht damit konnten sehr viele
personen ja krank sind einfach zu hause
bleiben haben medikamente bekommen und
sind am ende nicht ins krankenhaus
bekommen und die ganze belastung im
system war geringer und ich finde
deswegen das ganz legitim dass man sich
jetzt aktiv gedanken macht wie können
wir denn all diese vorsichtsmaßnahmen
ergreifen also schneller medikamente zur
verfügung stellen schnell und wirklich
gut dann auch die vierte impfung haben
andere maßnahmen die einfach uns diese
großen peaks sozusagen hoffentlich
ersparen können ergreifen damit wir eben
möglichst normal da durchkommen ist noch
kein ganz normales wir uns
gegen
nächsten kollege wird das ist es
dominik scheckkarte zdf herr lauterbach
geht schnell ich habe nur verstanden
wenn ich mich zum vierten mal impfen
lassen sollte im oktober kriege ich
wieder ein qr-code den ständig in der
korona vanek und das zertifikat wird
sofort nicht zwei wochen warten grün
richtig das ist der plan genau dass der
plan ist der dass für die krone waren
apps so verändern dass die dann neu also
eingestellten zertifikate das dann grün
aufleuchtet ohne zwei wochen ist der
jetzige genau das ist der jetzige plan
daran wird intensiv gearbeitet ist
natürlich klar dass wir diese auch dass
wir die wir sind ja in der abstimmung
und alle seine gründe weshalb sehr früh
mit den maßnahmen begonnen haben das
auch sehr früh besprechen naja
vierundzwanzigster achter schon kabinett
und so bald wie die dinge stehen wir das
dann umgesetzt aber dass es derzeit
genau das was wir beabsichtigen wer
programmiert hat sap weil öffentlich ein
sichtbar ist das bisher noch nicht und
wann kommt das da würde ich sie einfach
bitten dass ich also ihnen berichteten
wir dass programmiert zu dem zeitpunkt
wo die aufträge erteilt sind aber eben
darauf hingewiesen wir sind noch in der
phase des gesetzes beschlossen werden
muss
ich kann ich kann nicht kann ja nicht
vorab mitteilen wer uns dass
programmiert ohne dass die
entsprechenden unternehmen denn die
informationen von mir selbst bekommen
haben
dann der nächste fragesteller sie hatten
auch die gemeinde nicht genau sie hätten
sich gemeldet
wie man stellt und von zeit online laut
aber eine frage zu ihrer sicht auf die
todeszahlen
bisher liegt das infektionsschutzgesetz
als hauptkriterium fest wie die
schutzmaßnahmen das eben die überlastung
des gesundheitswesens verhindert werden
soll das haben sie ja stets auch auf die
todeszahlen verwiesen und damit auch
massnahmen gegründet die dann haben sie
stets als zu hoch bezeichnet
es ist unstrittig dass sie den
betrugsfall bedauerlich ist aber dennoch
würde ich gern genauer verstehen was
bewegt sie nach die folgen dieses
kriterium als einziger ich werde das in
keinem anderen wo wenn zu vertreten
das kriterium was nicht mal was ich auch
jetzt bei der regio türe des 928
insbesondere im absatz 6 auch nicht
konkret finden kann und die zweite frage
wann werden die bürger test wieder
kostenlos sagen wenn man sich dann von
dem aus gefreut testen können soll
ja also das nächste mal es kann in einem
solchen gesetz
infektionsschutzgesetz ja immer nur um
das primäre ziel gehen
wäre also verläufe und todesfälle zu
verhindern sagen infektionsschutzgesetz
zu diesem zweck also es gibt ja kein
also das ist ja kein gesetz also um sage
ja mal die wirtschaft zu schützen oder
was weiß ich und selbst werden es darum
geht was zum teil an abgeleitet ist also
dass die kritische infrastruktur in den
kliniken nicht überlastet sein sondern
dient das natürlich auch die kanuten zum
schluss nur also dem verhindern von
todes
wenn also ähnlich todesfälle dich
interessieren würde dann gäbe es auch
kein grund also dass ich mir gedanken
mache ist die intensivmediziner belastet
das ist ja in sich also wäre komplett ab
politik und ich kann auch nicht also
zwischen toten also durch kurven oder
durch alter krankheit und nach dem motto
der tod durch den auto und fahren muss
vermieden werden der tod verstehen cupid
also verlaufen ist mir gleich oder was
das ist das könnte ich dass das auch das
macht ganz in summe es geht immer auch
um die vermeidung von sterbefällen und
es geht auch um die vermeidung von
schwert für das ist darüber hinaus auch
darum gehen muss die also kritische
infrastruktur und das tägliche leben
also zu erhalten das ist ganz klar aber
ich wäre verläufe und tod müssen
original eine gewichtige rolle spielen
nachfrage warum fragt man es dann nicht
konkret ins gesetz rein da steht ja im
gesetzt was ich hatte eben schon also
ich habe eben also mehrfach auf diesen
kontext verwiesen ist aber klar dass er
nicht alle von die ihnen vorliegt aber
diejenigen die den text haben und er
wird ja jetzt aus den nächsten tagen
bekannt werden also in der also im text
selbst ist ja also beispielsweise
unter den punkten nicht eben genannt hp6
so zur begründung dieser zweiten stufe
wird ausdrücklich also darauf verwiesen
dass schwere fälle und todesfälle zu
vermeiden sind darüber hinaus kommt noch
die begründung des neuen texte sondern
wir das auch eine rolle spielen aber
ganz klar ich höre ich sage dass
trotzdem eine sehr relevante
diskussionen weil es gibt tatsächlich
die folgende position wenn jetzt jemand
also an einem autounfall oder was auch
immer verstärkt davor muss geschützt
werden
und zwar deshalb weil als solcher tod
format nicht also in person tot also ist
nicht vermeidbar das ist sozusagen im
normalen leben derweil vor dem tod durch
profi da kann sich jeder durch eine
impfung schützen diese debatte haben
immer gehabt als wir also die impfstoffe
frisch hatten und man legen gedanken
hatte und dass die impfung in jedem fall
foto sitzt da ist dann argumentiert
worden okay wenn leute an kurve
versterben er ist es zum schluss ihre
eigene show werden sich ja hinterlassen
können aber wenn jemand jetzt auf die
intensivstation wo es unterliegen lauter
kurve der kranke ist es ihm nicht
zuzumuten weil er hat ja durch die
impfungen der sich uns war es kann nicht
sein dass ein geimpfter nicht auf die
intensivstation kommen vallares vorliegt
diese hässliche debatte gegeben die habe
ich immer für falsch gehalten und zwar
erstens es gibt immer eine gruppe von
menschen da wirkt die impfungen nicht
ausreichend um den tod zu verhindern und
zum sollten wir haben auch keine
impfpflicht und daher ist eine solche
debatte immer falsch gewesen da er ist
das vermeiden von schweren verläufen und
auch von todesfällen auch immer ein
wichtiges ziel des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
es gab noch die frage nach den kosten
müssen bürger achten sie bitte der
kostenlose bürger das ja also ist es
aber für viele darüber wird weiter also
diskutiert zum jetzigen zeitpunkt ist es
so in vielen tests
der test quasi also kostenlos weil also
die betreiber der testzentren die drei
euro quasi aus ihren eigenen
gewinnmargen bezahlen und somit den test
abgeben also kostenlos auch für
diejenigen die nicht die qualifikationen
erfüllen dass sie eigentlich gar keine
der euro 6 beteiligen bezahlen müssten
trotzdem also bin ich jetzt mal dankbar
dass wir so weit gekommen sind wie wir
gekommen sind weil es ist ja kein
geheimnis dass der bundesfinanzminister
die bürger sind es zuerst gar nicht mehr
weiter finanzieren wollte wir haben uns
aber dann einvernehmlich gut gereinigt
und mit dieser einigung glaube ich
können wir jetzt ja auch ganz gut leben
was ich so also verfolge ist es so dass
die zahl der tests um etwa 30 prozent
gesunken ist ist aber weiterhin das eine
sage ich kann es kann dann ich habe gute
studie dazu aber wir haben also also ein
bisschen umhört bei den anbietern großer
testzentren von der
qualifiziere ich diese zahl sofort aus
etwas was wir nicht genau wissen wollen
wir aber noch arbeiten was prozess
herauszufinden aber ich glaube dass die
regelung die wir derzeit haben gut
funktioniert
ihr blick auf die uhr und die tatsache
dass wir die anschluss
regierungspressekonferenz haben die ich
um kurze fragen kurze antworten ich habe
jetzt noch fünf leute auf meiner liste
sie als erstes den hammer noch ein
beständiger mann und frau pauli und dann
soll ich die frage fragerunde auch
beenden bitte schön die
bälle eine frage an herr lauterbach herr
sander hat von der feststellung von
müdigkeit und gleichgültigkeit hat das
kurz erwähnt befürchten sie dass aus dem
herbst zunehmen wird und dann dazu führt
dass ein breiterer teil der gesellschaft
diese neuen restriktionen kritisieren
wird nein das glaube ich nicht also ich
glaube dass im moment die müdigkeit sehr
ausgeprägt ist und so hatte ich auch ein
sander verstanden also dass also im
moment feststellt und dem kann ich nur
zustimmen im moment ist das tatsächlich
ein thema womit man also nicht pumpen
also womit man sich nicht beliebt was
wenn man es aufwirft aber wir müssen
deshalb tun das ist unsere aufgabe
ja beim erste die lage eine andere sein
war dann haben wir wieder steigende
fallzahlen dann haben wir auch neue
impfstoffe haben wir neue möglichkeiten
ich glaube dass das thema dann also an
bedeutung gewinnen wird und wir müssen
gut vorbereitet sein wenn dem so ist mit
dem sieben punkte geplanten kommt er gut
durch wird man das auch anerkennen der
buchstelle
lauterbach noch mal zum thema isolation
da bin ich die
verlautbarungen rund um das
infektionsschutzgesetz in der letzten
zeit jetzt richtig wahrgenommen habe
planen sie da keine änderung andere
länder in europa machen das gibt es
bedingungen
unter denen sie davon abweichen von
ihrer bisherigen position es ist ja so
dass in einigen krankenhäusern
tatsächlich symptomlose infizierte in
deutschland jetzt schon arbeiten wie
stehen sie dazu sind sie da bereits
ausnahmen zuzulassen
ich nähe der antwort ist hier nahen war
es gibt dafür keine epidemiologischen
gründe die das also nahe legen würden
wenn man auch von der isolation abstand
nehme wurde dass er bedeuten dass
infizierte auf 10.000 automatisch
infizierte zur arbeit gehen und dann
noch mehr leute anstecken also was soll
denn das bringen und das wird auch in
der also klinik für das nicht helfen
weil die allermeisten die sich also mit
der fünf infizieren haben auch symptome
also vollkommen naive vorstellung dass
die pa 5 variante in der regel
symptomlos verlaufen würde ich kann
ihnen das so ich kann den fans
versichern dass das gegenteil der fall
ist und von daher die diese dieses diese
mehr als der massenhaft leute sind die
zufällig einen positiven test befund
haben und dann sich zuhause isolieren
müssen obwohl sie topfit und keinerlei
symptome haben diese das ist eine
ausnahme aber die maßen weil sie sich
testen lassen sie das nicht hätten
basisch und die ersten symptome an und
dann ist einfach die frage müssen die
anordnung zu hause bleiben oder können
sich das selbst aussuchen und gehen
möglicherweise und dafür gibt es keine
anhaltspunkte dass möchten wir nicht und
das würde auch ein teil dessen was wir
mit dem infektionsschutz aufbauen wollen
wir wollen ja mehr schutz haben sie so
für diese maßnahmen wirken ja ineinander
wieso sollte ich also eine maßnahme dann
also ergreifen die den schutz den wir
langsam aufbauen für den herbst dann aus
einer anderen stelle einreist
siehst du
herr lauterbach erlauben es um eine
frage zu den perimeter affen brocken
neben der pandemie auch existiert wann
können sie zusätzliche impfstoffe zu
sagen und werden sie nötigenfalls auch
weitere impfstoffe bestellen die
betroffenen gruppen sind ziemlich
verzweifelt weil sie aktuell nicht an
impfungen kommendes gab wenige tausend
und weiters gibt es den ersten moment
nicht viel gesagt dass zunächst einmal
deutschland hat sehr früh impfstoffe
bestellt wir haben
40.000 impfstoffdosen beim unternehmen
direkt gekauft more gibt nordic bewähren
und dann noch einmal um die 5000
bekommen aus den also konkret
kontingenten der eu somit hat kein
europäisches land ins also quantitativ
insgesamt oder auch so prozent war auch
nur annähernd
also hohen anteil an eben stoff bekommen
wie deutschland wir haben darüber hinaus
noch
200.000 impfstoff dosen für deutschland
alleine bestellt die anfang september
spätestens kommen sollen nur damit man
da sind wir in die relation setzen kann
in ganz europa sind durch die kommission
70.000 ebenfalls impfstoff dosen
bestellt worden somit deutschland
schafft hier im stoff weit über die
kontingente der europäischen kommission
hinaus aber es sind einfach also
produktionsengpässe die das unternehmen
hier also uns mitteilt ich hoffe aber
dass wir also die mit diesen 200.000
impfdosen die wir dann bekommen dass wir
dann also gut weiterkommen und also wir
setzen die hat so gut ein wie wir können
wir versuchen wirklich das ist sehr
wichtig die impfstoffe auch sozial
gerecht einzusetzen und das wird hier in
berlin aus meiner sicht also zum
beispiel sehr gut gemacht und mich
freuen wenn ein teil des impfstoffes der
jetzt in einigen bundesländern also
angekommen ist vertagt wurde es wird er
vielleicht noch in den brennpunkt berlin
also verlagert werden könnte weil wir
haben die überproportionale belastung
oder aber ein sammler bitten weil ich
weiß dass er mit der also versorgung
durch für die affen brocken ihren berlin
also wissenschaftlich und arbeits also
kliniker also sehr eng vertraut ist und
hier auch pionierarbeit leistet würde
ich ihn bitten das nur ein paar worte zu
sagen ich kann das noch ergänzen sie
haben vollkommen recht wir haben relativ
gesehen zu wenig impfstoff wir waren
auch sehr frühen kontakt haben darüber
gesprochen als die ersten fälle als das
im grunde klar wurde dass diese
erkrankung jetzt außerhalb der normalen
andy gebiete in afrika jetzt hier sich
rasch verbreitet und heimisch wird das
man unbedingt impfstoff braucht und dass
man und auch da noch mal das wort an die
stiko die sehr früh da eine gute
empfehlung finde ich ausgesprochen hat
indikation impfungen eben für die
menschen die es jetzt betrifft das sind
in der regel männer
und
und eben männer insbesondere wohl mit
sexualkontakten zu anderen männern und
deswegen auch eine entsprechend sprechen
empfehlungen die ich sehr gut finde klar
ich höre dass auch wir haben selber auch
impfstoff in der charité für unsere
patienten und klienten und das ist
zurzeit noch zu wenig erfreut nicht zu
hören dass jetzt mehr kommt allerdings
muss man sagen der impfstoff ist sicher
ein gutes tool aber auch noch mal als
information zurzeit sind die
allermeisten menschen mit einer
einmaligen dosis versorgt und wir wissen
über diesen impfstoff der wurde mal für
pocan entwickelt die pocken gibt es
schon lange nicht mehr und wir haben
eigentlich keine erkenntnisse zu wie gut
ist jetzt eigentlich eine fünfte person
geschützt vor der ansteckung mit diesem
appell pockenvirus dass sich
möglicherweise auch ein bisschen in der
ausprägung der erkrankung verändert hat
und deswegen geht auch weiterhin wenn
wir jetzt einen stoss hatte ist das
sicher gut aber gewisse
vorsichtsmaßnahmen hier weiter zu
ergreifen und zu gucken dass man eben
vielleicht die zahl der kontakte auch
limitiert um diesen weitere verbreitung
zu verhindern das ist weiterhin
angezeigt wir machen jetzt eine große
studie dazu die genau das untersuchen
soll wie gut ist jemand geschützt nach
einer impfung nach zwei impfungen das
ist kompliziert dazu gibt es weltweit
keine daten deswegen brauchen wir so
eine kombination aus einer guten
information über diese neue erkrankung
leben betrifft ist wie kann man sich
anstecken und eben auch mehr impfstoff
der dann glücklicherweise kommt da bin
ich auch sehr dankbar für wir haben noch
zwei minuten verspielte man geht es
irgendwie schnell oder
oder vielleicht könnte das bilaterale
machen weil ich muss wir müssen wir
wenigstens nicht durch lichtenegger
sonst genau sonst ging ich vor ärger von
co2 reduktion photocall ich stelle zu
das ist lieb hartmut krimmer soweit dann
bedanke ich mich für die kooperation
bedanke mich was kommen wenn die
bundespressekonferenz angehen
[Musik]